أجنبي
وتدمير الثقافات في الصين
للجراثيم ما دمروه في
الثقافة عمدًا أو
الشيء المتعلق بحرق الكتاب
والرايخ الثالث تجد كل شيء في التاريخ
أن الناس يدمرون الثقافة عن طريق الغرض
وهذا سيستمر
هذا للأسف مرض ثم
بعد ذلك  لديك حيود بسبب الحرب ، ثم
لديك تدمير من خلال التحديث من خلال
إهمال الأشياء ، لذلك لا يوجد
سبب اقتصادي للعديد من طرق
التدمير ولكن هناك العديد من الطرق
للتجديد ، لذا فإن القتال سيستمر ، وأنا
سعيد جدًا لأننا أخيرًا في عام 2016 في دن
هاق.  لديك قضية محكمة دولية
ضد أولئك الذين دمروا تمبكتو وتم
وضعهم في السجن أو شخص واحد ، وكانت
هذه هي المرة الأولى التي
جعلت فيها المحكمة الدولية التطهير الثقافي جزءًا من
جريمة حرب وهذا أمر مهم ، لذا ربما
يتطور القانون الدولي
ونأمل  هذا يتحسن ولكن بعد ذلك
نحتاج إلى القتال طوال الوقت
وهذا ما نحتاج إلى القيام به في كل مجتمع
أتذكر أن مزارعًا في
قريتي التالية حيث نشأت وأردت
تغيير منزله الزراعي ولكنه كان
ألمانيًا قديمًا  قال القانون لا ، هذا مستحيل ، لذلك
أخذ جراره ودخل
المبنى المدمر عمدًا ورأى أن
الغباء سيحدث طوال
الوقت ولدينا مجتمع عادي T
يجب أن نناقش سبب أهمية التراث
وما هي القوانين الأخرى التي يجب
حمايتها
ذكرى الماضي